all right a couple of quick stories i
didn't want to miss today uh there are
people on the right going absolutely
crazy because directv the satellite
television um provider has announced
that they are going to be dropping oan
one american news from their channel
lineup at a point in the near future now
if you don't remember oan you've got fox
news which is right wing corporate
you've got newsmax which is slightly
less corporate and slightly crazier and
then you've got oan which is slightly
less corporate than newsmax and even
more insane than newsmax it is a trash
uh just pond scum type channel
and um directv has announced that they
are going to be dropping the channel
directv to drop one american news
network as reported by npr
directv will be dropping the channel in
a surprise move sure to deal a massive
blow to the network that rose to
prominence during trump's presidency
bloomberg reported that satellite tv
provider directv
notified the owner of oan herring
networks inc that it would no care no
longer carry the company's two channels
when their contract expires the other
channel a wealth of entertainment dubs
itself a lifestyle channel featuring
luxury goods i didn't even know that
existed
directv said it made the decision quote
following a routine internal review a
directv spokesperson told npr the
company looks at many factors in terms
of whether to renew and one question is
does the programming appeal to a broad
enough base of customers
given increased programming costs and
competition for consumers directv says
it's basically a business decision that
was not in the best interests of directv
at t is a majority owner of directv and
you might remember we covered this when
it broke att has been facing calls to
drop oan
over its support of conspiracy theories
um directv spokesman declined to comment
on whether oan's editorial policies were
a factor rand paul the republican
senator
he i guess had directv now often times
people who have direct tv i i don't want
to say sometimes when people have direct
tv or dish it's because they live in a
rural area without cable i don't think
that applies to rand paul but rand paul
says he had directv he says he's
canceling it because they have dropped
they are dropping oan he says why give
money to people who hate us
um so
i guess supporting the exact type of
boycotts that he often
uh advocates against and then donald
trump during his rally in arizona over
the weekend also alluded to the oan
thing and he says the channel was
threatened
by woke executives
at a t
and he also says boycott a t take a look
at this but you know what one american
news has done a great job and here's the
story what just happened
the woke executives i don't know what
the hell they're doing they have so much
debt att is a company that is in serious
trouble
and they need a t
and a t saying that they may no longer
agree to carry this network that's doing
very well you know why because people
told them not to do it so maybe what we
should do is not use a t you know if we
did
if we did what they do
to republican companies we would have no
difficulty we just don't do it it seems
like not nice right but they're not nice
yeah
so uh i mean listen this is all again
their backwards version of freedom and
it's going to come up in the next
segment as well we talked about it at
the top of the show
they say let businesses do whatever they
want they say these woke boycotts are a
bad thing
they say we shouldn't regulate
businesses unless and then all of a
sudden directv makes a business decision
maybe influenced by a t also wanting it
made as a business decision and now all
of a sudden they go crazy and they say
it's suppression of speech and they say
all these different things no one has a
right to be on directv we're on directv
the david pakman show airs on a channel
called free speech tv
and it's on directv and dish network at
any time free speech tv could tell us
we're not going to carry the show
anymore and directv or dish could tell
free speech tv we're not going to carry
the channel anymore it's not a first
amendment issue
it's completely legal
it's
this backwards version of freedom that
they seem to only
care about when it's convenient for them
and then if it's no longer convenient it
goes out the window and the next story
quite frankly is another example of that
as well